there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
december to test for ourselves
we're starting off with these infinite
chrome flakes from denessa myricks this
product is so interesting i thought it
would be more like a gel but it's
actually this super liquidy and flaky
formula which made me really nervous i
used a brush to apply it and the way the
color shifts with these flakes is unreal
it was kind of hard to get it to show
all the colors on camera but you can see
it here on this hand swatch i did it's
so cool it is supposed to have that
texture so if you hate that don't get
this but i like the effect and i
actually got no fallout like once it
dried it did not move it does have a
slight tightening feeling as it's drying
but once it was fully dry it was totally
comfortable on the eyes i have a patrick
top blush that i already love so i knew
i would love this blush palette it comes
with three shades in both cream and
powder formulas this barbie pink color
was speaking to me so i went for that
one the pigment in these blushes is
incredible like you can really build
these up no problem the cream blush
blends really well on top of foundation
but i did get some patchiness when i
went over it with the powder one i think
you just need to be careful with how
much pressure you're using i'm super
heavy-handed when it comes to my makeup
and make sure you're tapping the blush
in and not swiping i think i prefer to
wear the cream and powder separately
rather than layered but i love the
formulas of both this is the moira
diamond days liquid shadow i thought i
was gonna love these because i've seen
so many people try them out and they
look amazing really great price point
but i could not get this liquid shadow
to behave at first i thought i could
apply it and then blend it out with my
finger but that was just removing all
the product so then i just applied it
with the applicator like the
instructions said but i had all these
harsh edges i just could not blend out
it's giving monster high it's giving
ghouls and goblins but nevertheless she
persisted and i tried it out a third
time and it looked better but not great
i'm not a liquid shadow kind of person
so it could just be me but i've never
tried a liquid shadow that's this
difficult to use please tell me what i'm
doing wrong you guys keep selling this
out but i finally finally got my hands
on the charlotte tilbury glow-gassing
beauty light wand in pink gasm which is
the blushy pink shade everyone is
obsessed with
i'm gonna say this the girls weren't
lying it's so
so good blending it was so effortless it
gives your cheeks this glowy flush look
oh my god and none of the foundation
underneath moved or got patchy and i had
already powdered my face at this point
the second this comes back in stock get
it next up is a product i actually
already use the milk hydro grip setting
spray mine is very well loved this is
overall a really nice setting spray it
has more of a dewy finish to it so it
melts makeup powders really nicely into
your skin but it also does help the
makeup last longer i like to spray this
in layers at different parts of the
application process to really make sure
nothing is going to move around too much
the transfer is super minimal if you do
get any at all and i just really like
how my skin looks when i use this
setting spray this is one of the coolest
products i've tried in a really long
time this is the genuine beauty face mud
and it's this super matte moussey cream
that can be applied to your eyes lips
and cheeks it was kind of intimidating
at first because it's so pigmented like
look at that but it was way easier to
control than i thought you just go in
little by little you can go from like a
wash of color like i did on my eyes and
cheeks to full color payoff like i did
on my lips it didn't remove any of the
product i already had on and i don't
know it's just unique and easy to use
and i love the velvety finish it has
[Music]